في صحيفه فاينانشال تايمز نجد ان صدور حكم
نهائي ضد اسرائيل في الشكوى المقدمه عليها
في محكمه العدل الدوليه حتى ان كان غير
قابل للتنفيذ يوجه ضربه لمكانه اسرائيل
ويغير اسلوب تعامل الدول الاخرى معها
الصحيفه نقلت عن خبيره في القانون الدولي
قولها لا اعرف كيف ستتمكن اسرائيل من
التعامل مع خساره تضر بسمعتها بشكل مباشر
صحيفه تايمز اوف اسرائيل كتبت ان اي حكم
ضد اسرائيل مهما كانت طبيعته قد تترتب
عليه عواقب دبلوماسيه وسياسيه وخيمه ومن
شان حكم ضد اسرائيل ان يؤثر في سير الحرب
المستمره ضد حماس في غزه من هنا يتعين على
اسرائيل ان تشعر بالقلق من خطر يتهددها قد
ياتي من لاهاي في صحيفتها ارتس نقرا مقالا
يرى ان الحرب مع حزب الله امر لا مفر منه
ولكن لا يتعين على اسرائيل ان تكون كون
مبادره اليها يبرر المقال طرحه بالقول ان
تصعيدا مع حزب الله قد يعني تدخل جماعات
مسلحه اخرى واذا لم تتدخل الولايات
المتحده للتعامل معها فستكون اسرائيل
وحدها في الواجهه بدء حرب جديده يعني ايضا
تاجيج المشاعر المعاديه لاسرائيل بين
الناخبين الامريكيين اكثر فاكثر صحيفه
واشنطن بوس نقلت شهادات معتقلين سابقين
لدى الجيش الاسرائيلي في غزه تصف ما سمته
انتهاك تعرضوا لها داخل مراكز اعتقال سريه
الصحيفه تقول ان منهم من قضى 17 يوما
معصوب العينين واجبر على الجثو على ركبتيه
لساعات متواصله ومن المعتقلين من اجبر على
التوقيع على وثيقه مكتوبه باللغه العبريه
لم يفهم محتواها ومن عرض عليه المال
للتجسس لصالح
اسرائيل صحيفه نيويورك تايمز نشرت تقريرا
يستعرض مجموعه من العقبات التي تعرقل وصول
المساعدات الى مستحقيها في قطاع غزه تستند
الصحيفه الى تصريحات عضوين في مجلس الشيوخ
الامريكي زارا معبر رفح مؤخرا ومسؤولين في
منظمات الاغاثه وصفوا عمليه تفتيش معقده
لجميع الشاحنات من طرف السلطات
الاسرائيليه وخلال وقت محدد تليها رحله
عبر طرق مدمره وفوق الانقاذ وصولا الى
حشود النازحين اليائسين والجوع يضاف الى
كل ما سبق تهديد دائم بالتعرض لاطلاق
النار
n